there's a lot of secret tricks you might
not know that can give you the edge in
halo infinite so we put together a list
of interesting stuff that can be done to
help you gain the extra edge on the
battlefield so if you're enjoying halo
infinite and want to see more tips from
us let us know with a like here we go
the grapple shot is one of the most
versatile new additions to the halo
gameplay loop pulling items to you
yourself to enemies and latching onto
the terrain to pull you across the map
but most players are under utilizing
this when it comes to traversal you
can't treat this like a plain old boring
a to b grapple you'll want to swing
yourself just like in titanfall and apex
while it's not as complex as respawn's
insane grapple system you'll want to
keep a similar mindset as soon as the
grapple lands on a surface turn your aim
off of where you attached to move your
body away from the wall then slowly turn
into the swing to get a farther angled
launch
another secret tip i can give is to try
and always be sprinting while grappling
you might be thinking but why well this
lets you do a neat trick on the landing
part of grappling when sprinting then
grappling and landing on a shallow
enough angle holding crouch will keep
your momentum and slide you much much
farther than by normally landing when
you have no high terrain around you this
can be combined with the grapple to the
ground by holding up then looking down
and crouching as you land this will
super slide it on real speeds useful for
getting out of a sticky situation or
catching someone off guard this is
something in the same spirit as
respawn's jump sling without the jump
this is also going to be really useful
in speeding up your travel on flat open
ground in halo infinite single player
campaign
and in situations where there's a grav
lift you can use grapples to throw off
your enemies normally grab lifts are a
one-way ticket but grapples can force
your way downwards and escape a
situation that an opponent can't follow
you
power items have
the arrived is one of my favorite new
pieces of equipment in halo infinite as
it has not only defensive capabilities
but it can be combined with a bunch of
other actions that makes it extremely
versatile it knocks away enemies and
reflects any projectiles back such as
grenades and rockets and if aimed down
it can act as a nice double jump
one of my favorite ways to use this
though is to pair with your own thrown
grenade if you throw a grenade then use
a repulsor you'll gain a little bit more
reach compared to chucking it normally
even farther if you bank it off a wall
or floor first
and on top of that since frag grenades
only start to explode when they touch
the floor you can throw it down then
repulsor it to roll the grenade and
immediately explode in the enemy's face
instead of the normal delayed explosion
pretty nifty and for lighter vehicles
such as the chopper or the mongoose you
can repulse her and mount the vehicle at
the same time to boost yourself for a
quick escape the timing is pretty tight
though so you may want to practice this
a bit before trying it out live in a
lobby
even though they're relatively weak drop
walls can give the enemy the advantage
of getting a few extra shots in in order
to win the fight but if you're up
against one just shoot the base it
destroys it in one hit
disrupters are probably one of my
favorite new guns when firing at first
it doesn't feel too special but it has a
couple quirks these shots barely do any
damage until the third shot lands which
the enemy then takes slow damage over
time while this damage is pretty
mediocre the moment it starts ticking is
a guaranteed 10 seconds that the enemy
cannot regenerate their shields
while this doesn't seem like a lot of
time in a gunfight 10 seconds is an
eternity and makes this weapon one of
the best support guns in the entire game
paired with good teammates or a strong
secondary weapon makes this really
deadly
both the shock rifle and disrupter have
several extra perks they can both emp
vehicles and disable them and conduct
electricity between players shooting
enemies near each other or any metallic
object like dropped guns or equipment
pads conduct electricity to players and
this can even be paired with a threat
sensor to make a makeshift deployable
shock pole
as the old saying goes
any bladed gun such as a mangler spiker
or shock rifle have just a tad more
melee damage than regular weapons but
this is especially good with the mangler
specifically one shot anywhere plus one
melee doesn't matter the order is all it
takes to kill a spartan
double kill
for any old school halo players lots of
legacy tricks still work today such as
ninja to jump over an enemy and hit them
from behind and combat evolved throwing
grenades at certain weapons to grab them
from a distance which can save you
precious seconds to clutch the match
ah the good old days victory
what was your favorite thing you learned
and if you have any interesting tips or
tricks too share them in the comments
below thanks for watching
[Music]
you